J'en étais toujours là.
Je crois vraiment que le cinéma nous apprend à voir.
La façon dont nous montrons
le monde change la façon dont nous voyons le monde,
et nous vivons à une époque où les médias
font un très mauvais travail
de représentation du monde :
la violence, les extrémistes,
que les évenements spectaculaires,
que des simplifications de la vie quotidienne.
Je pense que nous enregistrons
pour regagner une certaine complexité.
Pour réinventer la vie aujourd'hui,
nous devons créer de nouvelles formes d'images.
Et c'est très simple.
Muito Obrigado. (Merci beaucoup.)
(Applaudissements)
Bruno Giussani : Vincent, Vinvent, Vincent.
Merci. Nous devons nous préparer pour la présentation suivante,
et j'ai une question pour vous, et la question est :
vous arrivez dans ces endroits que vous nous avez montrés,
et vous portez une caméra
et je suppose que vous êtes bien accueilli
mais vous n'êtes pas toujours entièrement bien accueilli.
Vous entrez dans des rites sacrés,
des moments privés dans un village, une ville,
un groupe de gens.
Comment brisez-vous la glace
quand vous sortez votre caméra ?
V.M. : Je pense que vous la brisez avec votre corps,
plus qu'avec vos connaissances.
C'est ce que mes voyages m'ont appris,
de faire confiance à la mémoire du corps
plus qu'à la mémoire du cerveau.
Le respect, c'est faire un pas en avant,
pas faire un pas en arrière, et je pense vraiment
qu'en engageant votre corps dans le moment, dans la cérémonie,
dans les endroits, les gens vous accueillent
et comprennent votre énergie.
B.G. : La plupart des vidéos
que vous avez faites sont une seule prise.
Il y a très peu de montage.
Vous avez monté celles-ci
au début de la session à cause de leur longueur, etc.
Mais sinon, vous y allez et capturez
tout ce qu'il se passe devant vos yeux
sans trop planifier, est-ce le cas ?
C'est vrai ?
V.M. : Mon idée est que
tant que l'on ne coupe pas, d'une manière,
tant qu'on laisse la personne regarder,
de plus en plus de téléspectateurs se sentiront proches,
et se rapprocheront du moment,
de ce moment et de cet endroit.
Je pense vraiment que c'est respecter le téléspectateur,
de ne pas couper, passer d'un moment à l'autre,
de simplement laisser le temps se dérouler.
B.G. : Parlez-moi de votre nouveau projet,
« Hibridos » ici au Brésil.
Avant de venir à TEDGlobal, en fait,
vous avez voyagé dans tout le pays pour cela.
Parlez-nous en un peu.
V.M. : « Hibridos » est... Je pense que le Brésil,
loin des clichés, est le pays le plus religieux au monde,
le plus spirituel et le plus ouvert
en matière d'expérimentations spitiruelles.
C'est un grand projet que je réalise cette année,
effectuer des recherches dans différentes régions du Brésil,
dans différentes formes de cultes,
et essayer de comprendre comment les gens cohabitent
avec la spiritualité de nos jours.
B.G. : L'homme que vous allez accueillir maintenant
et Vincent va le présenter,
apparaît dans une de vos vidéos.
Quand avez-vous réalisé cette vidéo ?
V.M. : Il y a à peu près 4 ans, je pense
4 ans, lors de mon premier voyage.
B.G. : Un de vos premiers au Brésil.
V.M. : Un des premiers au Brésil, oui.
Je l'ai filmé à Recife,
là d'où il vient.
B.G. : Présentons-le. Qui attendons-nous ?
V.M. : Rapidement.
C'est un honneur pour moi d'accueillir sur le plateau
un des plus grands musiciens brésiliens de tous les temps.
Veuillez acceuillir Naná Vasconcelos.
B.G. : Naná Vasconcelos !
(Applaudissements)
(Musique)
Naná Vasconcelos : Allons dans la jungle.
(Applaudissements)